in the last video we took a stab at
modeling population as a function of
time and we said okay well maybe the
rate of change of population with
respect to time is going to be
proportional to the population itself
that that rate will increase as the
population increases and when you
actually try to solve this differential
equation you try to find an n of t that
satisfies this we found that an
exponential would work an exponential
satisfies this differential equation and
it would look like this visually it
would look like
this
it would look like this visually where
you're starting at a population of n
naught this is the time axis this is the
population axis and as time increases
population increases exponentially
now we said there's an issue there what
if thomas malthus is right that the
environment can't support
let's say that the environment can't
support medicine a new color let's say
that the environment really can't
support
more than
more than k
more than a population
more than a population of k then clearly
the population can't just go and go
right through the ceiling they're not
going to be able to have food or water
or resource resources or whatever it
might be they might generate too much
pollution who knows what it might be and
so this this this this first stab at
modeling population doesn't quite do the
trick especially if you are kind of in
malthus's camp and that's where pf and
once again i'm sure i'm mispronouncing
the name verhulst who is going to come
into the picture because he read
malthus's work and said well yeah i
think i think i can do a pretty good job
of modeling the type of behavior that
malthus is talking about and he says you
know what we really want
what we really want is
is something let me write it so the rate
let's try to model let's set up another
differential equation
let's set up another differential
equation and now let's say okay instead
of
you know if if the
if if if n is substantially smaller than
what the environment can support then
yeah that makes sense to have
exponential growth
that makes sense to have exponential
growth
but maybe we can dampen this or maybe we
can bring this growth to zero as n
approaches as n approaches k
and so how can we actually modify this
maybe we can multiply it by something
that for when n is small when n is much
smaller than k
this term right over here is going to be
close to one and when n is close to k
this term is equal is close to zero so
let me write that when n
so this is our these are our goals for
this term right over here
when n
n is much smaller
so much smaller
much smaller
than
than k
so now the population is not constrained
at all people can have babies and those
babies can be fed and then they can have
babies etc etc
then this thing should be should be
close to should be close to one and so
then you have essentially our old model
but then as n approaches k
when n
as n approaches k
then
then this thing should approach then
this term
this term or this expression should
approach zero and what that does is as n
approaches the natural
limit the ceiling to population then no
matter what this is doing this if this
thing is approaching zero that's going
to make the actual rate of growth
approach zero so they're going to have
food is going to be more scarce it's
going to be harder to find things
and so what what what can i construct
here dealing with n and k that will have
these properties and if you're if for
fun you might actually want to pause the
video and see if you can construct a
fairly simple algebraic statement using
n and k and maybe the number one if you
find the need
to to for an expression that has these
properties
well let's see what if we start with a
one
we start with a one
and we subtract we subtract n over k
we subtract
n
over
over my k is in pink
over k does this have those properties
well yeah sure it does when n is really
small or i should say when it's a small
fraction of k
then one mind this is going to be a
small fraction this then this whole
thing is going to be pretty close to 1.
it's going to be a little bit less than
one and when n approaches k as n gets
closer and closer and closer to k
then this thing right over here is going
to approach one which means this whole
expression is going to approach zero
which is exactly what we wanted and this
thing right over here is actually and
this this is used in the tons of
applications not just not just in
population modeling but that's kind of
one of its first its first uh kind of
reasons or motivations this differential
equation right over here is actually
quite famous
it's called the logistic differential
equation
logistic differential equation
logistic
differential
differential equation and in the next
video we're actually going to solve this
and it's actually a this is a separable
differential equation you could you can
actually solve it just using standard
techniques of integration it's a little
bit hairier than this one so we're going
to work through it together and we're
going to look at the solution the
solution to the logistic differential
equation is the logistic sometimes those
just well the logistic function which
once again is really is essentially
models population in this way but before
we actually solve for it let's just try
to interpret this differential equation
and and think about what the shape of
this function might look like
and to do that
to do that actually let me
let me get actually it's nice to see the
faces so let me draw
let me draw some axes here
let me draw some axes here so that's my
time axis that is my population axis
let me scroll up a little bit because
sometimes the subtitles show up around
here and then people can't see what's
going on
so let's think about a couple of
permutations a couple of situations so
if our initial if our initial
if our if our n at time equals zero
remember n is a function of t if at time
equals zero n is equal to zero
so if n is equal to zero then this term
is going to be zero and then your rate
of change is going to be zero and so
you're not going to add any population
and that's good
because if your population is zero how
are you going to actually be able to add
population there's no one there to have
children
so there's actually one constant
solution to this differential equation
which is just n of t
that is n of t
is equal to zero and that's neat that
this satisfies the logistic differential
equation hey if your population starts
at zero
if n sub naught is zero then you're just
going to be at zero forever well that's
actually what would happen in in in real
life there's no one there to have kids
now let's think about another situation
what if our population what if n naught
is equal to k
what happens if n naught is equal to
what happens if n naught is equal so
that's k right over there what happens
if at time equals 0
this is our population
well if n is equal to k then this is 1
minus 1 then this thing is 0 and so our
rate of population change is going to be
0. so essentially if my population is 0
then after a little bit of time my
population is still the same k
if my rate of change of population is
zero that means my population is staying
constant
and so
my population is going to stay there at
k and that's actually believable malthus
would actually probably say that you're
going to have you know maybe it grows a
little bit beyond the capacity of the of
the environment and then you have some
you know some some flood or some
hurricane or some famine and it goes
around but for our purposes you can
never model anything perfectly for our
purposes that's that's pretty good you
know you're at the limit of what the
populate of what the environment can
handle so you just kind of stay there so
that's actually another constant
solution that n of t if it starts
if it starts and now you can kind of
appreciate why initial conditions are
important if you start at zero you're
going to stay at zero if you start at k
you're going to stay at k so that is n
of t just stays at k
but now let's think of a more
interesting scenario let's assume an
let's assume an initial population
that's someplace between 0 and k so this
is going to be
this is going to be i'm going to assume
initial population that is
someplace it's greater than zero so
there are people to actually have
children and it is less than k so we
aren't fully maxing out the environment
or the land or the food or the water or
whatever it might be so what's going to
happen
so and once again i'm just going to kind
of sketch it and then we're going to
actually solve it in the next video
so when n is a lot less than k it's a
small fraction of k you're going to it's
going to you know this term is going to
be the main one that's influencing it
because this is a small fraction of k i
mean even the way i drew it it looks
like it's about a i don't know it looks
like it's about a a sixth or a seventh
or an eighth of k so it's one minus one
eighth so it's 7 8 it's going to be 7 8
times
times this so really this is what's
going to
dictate this is what's going to dictate
what our rate of growth is and if this
is kind of dictating it we're kind of
looking more of a
well let's just think of it this way as
the population grows the rate of the
rate of the rate of change is going to
grow
so it's going to look it's going to look
something
it's going to look something like this
as our population gets larger our
our slope is getting higher and it's
getting steeper and steeper
but then as n approaches k then this
thing is going to become this is going
to be close to 1 minus close to 1. and
so this is going to become a very small
number it's going to make this whole
thing approach 0.
so as n approaches k
the whole thing the rate of change is
going to
flatten out and we're going to asymptote
towards k
and so the solution
the solution to the logistic
differential equation should look
something like this depending on what
your initial conditions are if your
initial condition is here maybe it does
something like this if your initial
condition's here maybe it does something
like
something like this and once again and
this is what's fun about differential
equations before even doing the fancy
math you can kind of get an intuition
just by thinking through the
differential equation of what it is
likely what it is likely to be down here
or when when when n is much smaller than
k
its rate of increase is increasing as n
increases and over here as n gets close
to k its rate of of increase is
decreasing now let's actually in the
next video actually solve for what n of
a solution to this and and see if that
if that confirms what our intuition is